welcome all my name is NL Jackson I'm
associate professor of literature at MIT
David thorburn the communications Forum
director unfortunately unable to join us
tonight it is however my great pleasure
to introduce what happens to be our last
MIT Communications Forum event of the
term news or entertainment the press in
modern political campaigns uh our
distinguished speakers are here now but
it's my job to and my pleasure to
introduce to you our moderator for
tonight's discussion Seth manukan
sitting right here to my right Seth
co-directs mit's graduate program in
science writing he's a contributing
editor at Vanity Fair he's the author
most recently of the panic virus the
true story behind the vaccine autism
controversy which won the National
Association of science writers 2012
science and Society award he's also the
author of the 2006 New York Times
bestseller feeding the moner monster how
money smarts and nerve took a team to
the top about the Boston Red Sox and
2004's hard news the scandals at New
York Times and their meaning for the
American Media in 2002 and 2003 he was a
senior writer at Newsweek it's my
pleasure to welcome Seth but before I do
I wanted simply to uh call your
attention to the screen behind me and to
the MIT uh the eth annual MIT uh media
in transition uh conference uh on which
I'm serving on the organizing committee
U Nick Monfort and uh James parody
sitting in the audience are as well on
the organizing committee for this I
think we put together a great conference
uh registration for the conference is uh
free but we do ask that you register in
advance so uh please um uh save the date
and uh and we'll hope to see you there
uh but it's my pleasure now to introduce
Seth manukan
Seth
um thank you very much so I'm going to
uh now I will introduce uh mark and
tanasi um and then we're going to spend
somewhere between 40 minutes and and an
hour um talking among the three of us
and then we'll devote the second half of
the form to questions from all of you um
so uh if something comes up during our
conversation that you want us to expand
on uh
just write it down or remember it and we
will definitely have a chance to do that
um tanasi uh coats is has been for this
Academic Year a member of our MIT family
which we're very excited about he's a
2012 2013 Martin Luther King Jr visiting
scholar um he's also a senior editor at
the Atlantic where he both blogs and uh
writes regularly for the magazine um and
one of his pieces from last year uh fear
of a black president is uh right now A
finalist for the national magazine award
is that May 2nd yes yes yes so um uh
everyone send Positive Vibes to New York
City on May 2nd uh um he's the author of
a uh a memoir that came out in 2008 y um
called the beautiful struggle a father
two sons and unlikely road to manhood um
and uh that's about his experiences
growing up in Baltimore with his father
and brother um Mark McKinnon uh is a
senior adviser at Hill and Nolton is
that right Nolton you pronounce all
right strategies um he's he's probably
best known as a political consultant um
a job that he had in the 9s um and then
left and and then came back in the
2000s um uh advised uh the second
President Bush on his uh two
presidential campaigns um and as well as
Senator McCain and uh two years ago
started
um an organization called No Labels
which is designed to Foster more um uh
better working relationships between the
two political parties um and there have
been some some No Labels successes just
within the past 24 hours um in in terms
of the uh the gun
legislation uh he also is a regular
columnist for The Daily Beast um and the
London Daily Telegraph and were the you
were the editor of the of the uh of the
paper at uh University of Texas Austin
what is the daily Texon uhuh so um he is
both a member of the media and uh has
also worked in politics so I wanted to
start by getting a little bit of of both
of your backgrounds um just because
they're in their own ways a little bit
unusual um Mark I know you uh spent some
time working with Chris
kristoferson yeah yeah you're really
digging up the past
here yeah I uh I actually piing out the
past means the second paragraph on
Wikipedia so
um yeah I had I my career kind of is in
three different buckets I guess the
first one was uh I was in the music
business and I I loved music I grew up
on music and had uh there was an old
folk singer named Judy Collins who was
my babysitter when I was growing up and
so I'd fell in love with music really
early on and then was this to was that
to supplement her singing career that
was kind of before she was she she was
taken off her father was a piano teacher
in Denver and uh and she before she took
off she that's how she supplemented and
uh and then I uh I loved writing I loved
I loved writing generally I mean that
that was kind of my entree into politics
journalism
and uh music and uh so I I started a
little band in high school and which
attracted the attention of Chris
kristoferson who tried to produce our
band and get us a record deal which
didn't happen which is not surprising if
you heard the tapes but I I got so
inspired by it all uh that I ran away
from home in high school and hitchhiked
to
Nashville and uh and then just banged
around Nashville for four or five years
and and he was very generous and let me
live in his apartment and sort of
tolerated me because I I really was not
a very good songwriter but uh but I had
a lot of fun it was a great thing to do
as a young teenager kicking around
Nashville and then I ended up in Texas
uh playing at A Folk Festival realized
after a couple years years of then I
discovered Austin moved there and then
played around there for a while and then
at a time I guess one of the times I
really exercised some judgment in my
life was realizing my musical
limitations and realize that on the on
the arc that I was on I was going to end
up at the uh Cambridge holiday and as
the second act when I was 50 years old
there was just a lot of great talent
around so I I decided that I'd try a
little higher education and
uh then I got into journalism and was
covering writing a lot about politics
cuz I like politics and wrote about it
this was when you were in college uhhuh
yeah and then which I started a little
later in life but um and then uh a local
state senator ran for the US Senate and
I I've been covering him and I went over
and volunteered and did his campaign
and uh had a exciting primary then I got
killed in the general election but
that's when I discovered you can fail
upwards in politics and went to work for
the governor and then then got The
Campaign bug and went to Louisiana then
moved to New York and worked for a one
of the gurus of our business in New York
and work races all around the country
and around the world and and then when
you say the governor in Texas that was
an Richards actually was before that
this was Mark White who who's also a
Democrat that's right yeah yeah and I
had a I had so I started off as an
anarchus Banning Student Government
initially uh at the University of Texas
and then uh in Texas at the time there
was only the democ there were it was two
parties but it was a Democratic party
and the conservative Democratic party
there was no Republican party which is
astonishing when you think how quickly
things have changed there in 1990 when
Anne Richards was elected and I worked
for Anne Richards uh every
constitutional office in the state and
there are 18 or 24 of them I forget
every one of them was a Democrat today
all of them are
Republican anyway uh so I got I came
back to Texas started a
firm worked in politics worked for Anne
Richards uh then this is now in the 90s
yeah and as you not that I kind of
bailed out of politics for a little
while and that was when she ran against
George W bush uh in '96 in '94 okay and
uh uh so I state did you did you leave
did you leave politics at that point
because you were conflicted about that
race or no no I I I I was actually
believe it or not I was concerned about
the partisan nature of politics and just
had kind of tired of it and uh and just
was pursuing some other I was working on
some education reform efforts and I was
just kind of burned out at the time and
and then I got to then on this education
efforts through that I was got George W
bush I met him and got him interested in
some charter school things and then got
to know him and then this is after he
was governor this is after he was
elected in '94 and
then I was kind of involving in my life
and be had become a little bit more
conservative and had issues with the
Democratic party and I liked his
compassionate conservative message and
he was pushing at the time you know he
was very uh vocal about things like
immigration reform and education reform
which were two very passionate issues
for me at the
time and we became friends and then he
asked me to help him in his reelect in
1998 and his and the lieutenant governor
who was a Democrat uh a legendary
Democrat and mentor to him asked
me if I would consider it and and he
endorsed Bush over his own godson who
was running against Bush at the time
anyway so uh I I I got aboard with uh
with George W bush and his reelect and
then did both the presidential campaigns
and
tanasi you um tell us a little bit about
your path to journalism I know you
started at Washington City paper uh
about a little over a decade ago is that
right no I wish it was a little over a
decade ago uh it's been
uh almost 17 years so a little under a
little under two decades ago um wow I am
getting old um I was in college and DC
at Howard University getting I am old um
I was in college at Howard University I
started in journalism when I was 20
years old and um I wanted to be a poet
before that um I was not a very good
poet um you do have a knack for choosing
careers that don't offer a lot of
financial I do I do I do I do I do I had
that um you're not going to make much
money face um and and I knew that that
you know I was Bor with that cloud I was
not a good student in school um so I I
knew that you know you know there was
there weren't you know riches out there
waiting for me so I I um but I did like
to write I did like to write no matter
how you know whether I was good at it or
bad at it I did I did enjoy writing and
um when I was 20 I had a friend who I
knew who was a much better poet than me
who had interned at uh Washington City
paper uh the editor was all of our
mutual friends everybody's mutual friend
David
Carr and um I sent him a little chatbook
of really bad poetry
and somehow that convinced him that I
should be a
journalist and that that that's it
that's my career that really is it I
mean I never turned around after that
and so when at at age 20 so you left
College made a decision to leave Howard
you know it's funny because when I got
there I knew that I shouldn't be there
it was pretty clear to me I did not
belong there and when I got that job for
what reason cuz I had never been good at
school and I you know I'd love to read
but I wanted it's funny I'm having I
have a conference with my with my son's
teachers tomorrow and it's like a mirror
image of exactly who I was I don't I
don't know what I'm going to
do how old is your son he's uh 12 he'll
be 13 this year and he's just like me um
but I I you know I love to read I wanted
to do what I wanted to do when I wanted
to do it and the cool thing about
journalism was that's that was pretty
much the job description I mean you did
have deadlines but you had to pitch
stories it had to be your idea and you
know I think journalism works at its
best when the person executing the
journalism is fanatically curious
and I did have that I had that as a
child you know um and you know it's
pretty much carried over I I could not
believe that somebody would pay you to
do journalism like the question that you
were really really burning to answer um
if you could you know convey that
burning to an editor you know they would
say okay go answer the question and I'll
see you in a week or two and that was
like amazing to me and then they give
you money um I was giving people money I
was giving a college money you know and
I couldn't really answer the burning
questions that that I wanted I'm making
a great appeal for mit's writing program
right
now but that just that really that that
bugged me out I I couldn't believe that
so I knew I should have left when I was
20 I it took about it was like a bad
divorce you know it took you know about
another year I was in and out on and off
and eventually I finally pulled the
trigger and said okay this is where I am
and that was it that was my life and
so starting out did you you were in
Washington obviously um uh were you and
and 20
that that you were in Washington uh then
in the late '90s and early 2000s right I
left like 2,000 I about 99 2000 so
certainly there was a lot going on
politically during those years did you
were you drawn at all to covering
politics or were you interested in
covering politics I wanted to cover
music but working for David you had to
cover politics you just you had to cover
local DC you just did or else you
wouldn't work there it was that simple
um you could write about music too but
you really really there were very few
people who just got the luck of being
Arty folks and that uh was frankly uh a
great contribution because I think if
left up to me I would never have learned
how to report um but you just you had to
you had to and I think um I I still
think you know
um the sheer challenge of walking up to
someone who you do not know with a pen
and a pad and asking a question it it I
mean it's one of the scariest things in
the world um but it's so important to be
able to do and to be able to master and
to put yourself out there and to
understand um that just because you're
curious no one owes you anything you
know they don't have to be nice to you
um and I learned that in DC because this
was DC I mean you had to cover DC I mean
this was not uh uh Washington you know
this was local local Metro local Metro
politics yeah right right um one thing
that that we're going to come back to is
the ways in which political reporting
and coverage of politics has changed
over the last 15 or 20 years and um it
it it strikes me that both of you are in
an interesting position because you are
both of this world but uh you only in
since 2008 um uh and you were not
writing about journalism and for the
most part I guess you are now somewhat
but um over the last 15 or or so years
have seen this Evolution as Insider
Outsiders right um and that's that's
something that I I want to come back to
but we'll we'll I want to also make sure
that we get to the present with both of
you until then so um uh you went to uh
you worked for President Bush um we were
talking earlier um and I think you
didn't remember but on Election night in
2000 the the first time that Bush was
announced as the winner Mark and I were
standing next to each other um in Austin
uh I was covering um the campaign and
was with Jake Tapper who is now the CNN
yeah he's got his own show on CNN a yeah
he's got a show yeah right uh Jake
Tapper another person who got his start
around the same time with David Carr and
yes by the way for those of you may all
know who David Carr is but for those of
you who may not he's this legendary New
York Times uh repor who reports on
broadly media
technology cultural sight guy he's a
brilliant brilliant guy and uh a
connective tissue for a lot of people in
our business and and he's going to be
here next week so you should yeah we're
not talking about the
quarterback
um yes we're talking about this person
that's probably the yeah a great
portrait be speaking next week yes she
is speaking with tanasi and I anyway um
there's there's David Carr the not the
one who's not Jud appow for um the
person who created girls um uh so um
it's interesting to me that
you worked with President Bush um and
then since the end of the Bush
Administration certainly your your
public work has been very focused on um
forging bipartisan coalitions and and I
think there are a lot of people who see
that Administration is a very partisan
time yeah yeah uh great question uh
here's what's interesting
about that period and the the overall
frame
of not just those eight years but the
proceeding time and the and the and the
context which which a lot of people
either weren't around or don't
remember but uh first of all as I as I
mentioned in in Texas when George W Bush
was governor
he worked very closely with the this
this this legend that I mentioned who
lieutenant governor who was kind of a
Sam rer Lynden Johnson type of guy been
around forever and he was his mentor to
George Bush and they worked so well
together and and a Democrat and oh yeah
huge Democrat and in Texas lieutenant
governor and Governor are not elected
together no they're not and in fact the
lieutenant governor arguably has more
power than the governor and but as I
mentioned he felt so strongly about Bush
that he endorsed Bush over his godson
that's how strongly felt so very
bipartisan and that's that's part of
what attracted me to to him as I mention
on these other issues but uh I mean he
was talking about being a different kind
of Republican compassionate conservative
agenda all these things uh which which
were attractive to me but also one of
one of the things that you may remember
because you were around is and I think
it'd be an interesting exercise to take
some some of his speeches from 1999 take
some of Obama's speeches from 2007 mix
them up and I bet you you couldn't tell
the difference because they both were
talking about changing the culture of
Washington DC working in a bipartisan
fashion so but is that is that just the
same way that if you took any politician
some speech from any period and and no
no I don't think so I no I think they
very uniquely were focused on that
particular message about changing the
tone of Washington working in a
bipartisan fashion I mean that's not
what Romney ran on and that's not what
McCain ran on and that's you know I mean
they really I mean the the language
itself was very particular
uh on that issue the Washington is
broken language that certainly they're
not the only two politicians who've
adopted that no but but but but I mean
the characteristics in the language and
the tone was just it was just I mean it
really as I think back on it I was I was
when I saw Obama's speeches I was like
God that you know I went back and looked
at some Bush's early speeches I was like
Jesus they're say a lot of the same
thing right and for for for certainly in
both cases they hit the wall in
Washington and met the Practical
realities of Washington and for reasons
that are similar and different I mean I
think there are just the realities that
they both confronted about just the
entrenched nature of the special
interest in Washington uh that we could
talk about for hours and how it got to
be that way and how it's different now
than it used to be which is which is an
interesting subject but um but then Al
bush had the recount which poisoned the
well for him right from from the get-go
I mean Democrats didn't you know a lot
of Democrats and important Democrats on
the hill didn't see him as a legitimate
President right and that just that that
got things off to a very bad start not
not that you know arguably he wasn't
complient in his own way over time but
uh you remember even despite that in the
first couple of years with Ted Kennedy
he worked a very bipartisan fashion Got
No Child Left Behind done number other
things and same thing happened with
Obama in a different way with the sort
of the birthers on the Republican side
also
finding IR rationale for thinking that
he was a legitimate president so it just
creates this huge
hyperaroused both of their presidencies
and that I mean that's also just part of
the evolution of politics in Washington
and the and the media and you know this
is kind of on the topic that we're
talking about which it's just harder and
harder uh uh and and more challenging I
mean I I think every every four years
it's an impossible job in my opinion and
it's an amazing uh challenge for body I
don't want to go too far down this
rabbit hole but but it struck me that
the parallel there between Democrats who
were viewing bush is not legitimate
because of the recount and Republicans
who are viewing Obama is not legitimate
because they don't believe he was born
in the United States one of those is a
more reality based argument sure yeah no
no I I caned that completely I'm just
saying that people out there who were
inclined to be that way anyway found
their own rationale and reason and they
went to those kind of bases to say well
here's why and and then and that and and
that reality affected the whole
environment I think right right and
tanasi so in 2008 by that point you had
been at the Atlantic for a little while
is that right I came on in I was
covering two so yes I guess I I'm I came
in 08 I did came in 08 yeah um and you
started then writing more about National
politics right was that because of
something unique about that race was it
about Obama's entry into that race or
was it just where you were in your the
evolution of your career I I gotten laid
off from Time magazine that was probably
the most important
factor very important factor um I gotten
laid off and this thing called blogging
had happened and I had at that point
been in journalism for 12 years
and before blogging I think this is like
a sea change this is a really really big
sea
change no matter how excited you were
just went on this whole thing about
enthusiasm and you know that's great but
no matter how excited you were you
really before you know the rise of blogs
you really had to convince somebody else
uh in order to you know make make your
voice heard you mean convince someone
else get convince someone to let it to
right use their pages right exactly
exactly exactly and then this thing came
up where there was suddenly no border
anymore where you know you could just
sort of throw it out in the world and if
the world liked it that was great and if
they didn't you you know you found that
out too uh so 2008 uh I I finished uh I
begun uh freelancing for the for uh for
for the magazine uh I finished my first
the attic for the Atlantic yes um I had
finished my first book and I had nothing
to do uh my unemployment checks had run
out and um I just started blogging just
you know out out of nowhere you know I
was still you know dinking around in
freelance in various places and um it
did strike me that there was somebody
who was running for president who might
win who looked a little different than
everybody else that was on my mind
right I thought as a journalist I should
document that you know and it just you
know it I got pretty lucky I got to go
out you know to Denver for the
convention um and ended up in a you know
a few key places it was it was
fascinating it was it was such an
education it really really was and and
so when you uh when you started covering
National politics oh oh something else
too the other thing that struck me was
at that point like there was coverage of
Obama and it really became clear and you
know we don't have to spend too much
time talking about this but this is an
important point from when I realized
that you know maybe I should do some of
this it was very
clear that the vast majority of people
covering the Obama
campaign had no understanding of Black
America at all um of its history of its
politics of anything of absolutely
anything and I thought that maybe I
could you know not saying I have any
sort of total knowledge but it was clear
to me that I had a little bit of an
advantage is that because there were no
black reporters on the campaign Trail no
there were there were there were I
actually think I think part of it is is
the motive of of what journalism is um
journalism as a form right now uh one of
my big beefs is totally
ahistorical um right you know uh and and
I I think that's a huge I mean you can
just to give a specific example
uh Barack by the time Barack Obama ran
in
'08
um
Black America was pretty used to
African-Americans running for president
it had seen Shirley Chism it seen Jesse
Jackson twice it had seen Al Sharon I
think at that point twice I had had seen
Allan Keys it it was very used to
African-Americans running and I I don't
think uh people quite got that you know
so if you if you you know go back to 08
when you say people didn't quite get
that I don't think media got that so it
was like surprise for instance that
Hillary Clinton was beating him among
African-American voters which made total
sense to me uh because African-Americans
you know they got the right to vote
through a you know a hard fight they
treasure that right to vote they want to
back a winner right and it's very
practical and very tactical about
there's nothing surprising about it at
all and if you understood the history of
African-Americans you wouldn't be
shocked by you know the support for
Hillary Clinton at all and so when I
that was like one of the earliest things
that you know really struck me that
folks don't quite understand what's
going on here and that was a big big
prompting for me to go ahead and did you
have any sense cuz I know when I started
covering the 2000 campaign
I had never covered National politics
before and I I I felt almost right away
like there I was had just come into some
tribal thing that I no one had told me
what the vocabulary was and what the
rules were and um in some ways I think
my understanding of politics and of that
campaign was helped by the fact that I
wasn't of that world did you have a
similar experience yeah I did well I
when I remember when when I went out to
Denver and at the time I was writing
about Michelle Obama and the uh the
thing that they do where like um the
they who's they I'm sorry the media of
which I am a part of the thing we do um
I I would never do that again though um
where uh you know you you pick up a
magazine or a newspaper and they profile
some somebody and uh you'll always see
this kind of scene that really I guess
it's supposed to convey humanness that
doesn't really make any sense like
Michelle Obama was wearing this and she
walked past this and and I got to see
that they actually set that up right you
know that like Michelle Obama's handlers
tell you you can be here at this point
in time you don't get to ask her any
questions but she's going to walk past
and that'll give you your color for your
story and I totally you know regardless
of whether that conveys any truth of
anything in fact I was out I was out
there with David Carr David Carr was
there at the DNC I'm sorry he keeps
coming up this is hard you guys should
come next week um I was out there and I
said cuz I didn't I didn't and David had
been with you in 2000 and had experience
with this and I said I have gotten
limited exposure to this woman they have
put me in all of these places where I
don't know like this means nothing you
know I've seen these scenes appear in
other reporters you know pieces but they
it has no meaning at all for any reader
it's not interesting at all and he told
me you have to figure out what it means
you have to put your own thing on it you
just have to do it mean you have to
figure out what it means to put your own
thing on it because you're not going to
get anything else yeah you're not going
to get it from her I mean you can go
report elsewhere you go talk to other
people but you're not that's that's
that's what they're going to give you
and you're going to have to bring
something to Bear to it um which was
sort of just like I I didn't realize how
planned and how choreograph it's very
depressing I really really didn't
realize how planned and choreograph the
coverage of of of of presidential
candidates is and and Mark so is that
something that talking about um whether
political reporting is functions as news
or entertainment is that something that
has evolved D or changed dramatically
over the last decade or so I mean even
in 2000 um where I spent a lot of time
with the McCain campaign that campaign
was obviously
notoriously um shoot from the hip and
gave all kinds of access and so I'm
sorry not to cut you up but did they do
any of that you have to be here you know
look at this at this specific time M
campaign in 2000 he had I mean it was
almost pathological he had reporters
with him all the time um you know he had
reporters on his bus all the time and
was the journalism better
[Music]
um I don't know uh I think it was yeah
it was different certainly of the McCain
campaign and I think in fact and this
was something I was going to ask you
that it forced Bush to respond
differently to the media because at when
McCain started getting more traction all
of a sudden when I was with bush he
would go from being sort of sequestered
in the front of his press plane to
coming back much more there were all
sorts of um uh you know Karen Hughes
became much more willing to have people
interact with um uh Bush on a less
scripted stage yeah well here's the
dynamic
tension you're right about McCain and
that that was you know McCain got a a
ton of media
love uh in 2000 for being kind of the
the Wide Open Candid un scripted guy and
that that kind of that got him a you
know a lot
of uh that got him up the runway a good
ways and and certainly in the Bush
campaign the joke was that his base
constituency was media right right um
but then so but that all evolved and
then over the course of time and this
has to do a lot with I think the
evolution of of the media and how it
works differently now you you have the
Jor you know the makaka the Senate
moment with you know just sort of the
full body coverage and so candidates and
campaigns became
more concerned about that kind of access
because they were just afraid that there
was going to be a moment because it's
all being captured all the time and
unlike old days dur the Kennedy days
where something like that would happen
they' say you know they just all kind of
agree that we' keep that you know but
but that's the rules now there are no
rules I mean in terms of kind of letting
you know something unscripted happened
and not report it that's not going to
happen anymore so in fact just the
opposite and where we see sort of secret
recordings right of people trying to get
every moment even those that aren't
supposed to be public so that changes
the behavior and and it changed McCain's
behavior in 2008 because uh he kind of
started off that way but then the
campaign jumped in and just said you
because he would go off message as they
call it and kind of you know ruin the
storyline that they were trying to
create so they so what happened the
response has been that the campaigns
have become more scripted as a response
to the media but ironically at the same
time that all that's happening voters
have become much more skeptical about
the information that they get from
campaigns because they right they're
they rightly perceive it as being
scripted and and so they find it not
believable not credible and so actually
I I I I I I I I have a presentation that
I do that I've been doing for 15 or 20
years called the architecture of a
political message and and I keep
adapting and evolving the most recent
chapter that I dropped into it was the
importance of authenticity in today's
media
because because if I mean advert
political advertising is almost
completely meaningless because people
just assume they're being lied to and
I've got a I'd like to talk about that
at some point before we're done because
I got a particular example about that
that I like to talk about which has to
do with truth and campaigns today and
what what's happened to the the truth
but uh so the the the moment that I used
to describe to reflect the the value of
authenticity was Hillary Clinton in the
2008 campaign you remember when Barack
Obama won Iowa Shock the World suddenly
he's up 20 points in New Hampshire his
pollster tells them it's in the bag No
need we don't even need to pull for the
rest of the week it's done and then
Hillary Clinton 24 hours before that uh
election had this completely spontaneous
moment on the campaign Trail she's
exhausted Ed tired somebody throws her
kind of a softball question about you
know well how are you doing and and she
kind of she has this very vulnerable
moment she chokes up she chokes up kind
of tears up and I remember initially
reports like oh she's crying she's done
then you see the video and you go wow
that's a really human moment you know
I've never seen this side of this person
that was that was an interesting moment
because it showed on on one level the
disconnect that there was between the
way the public was perceiving events and
the way the camp the way the the
political press was perceiving events
because the initial media reaction to
that was if Obama was going to win by 20
points before now he's going to win by
40 points exactly right yeah and he lost
yeah 24 hours later right and that
that's how
dramatically that moment of authenticity
because people just saw kind of behind
the curtain they said oh this is the
real person and and uh and that's how
powerful that can be if if so talking
about the the campaigns have gotten more
scripted which I think everyone would
agree is true but in terms of the
information that the public gets you
know in in 1960 you had Ben Bradley went
on to be editor of the Washington Post
at the time uh was writing for Newsweek
going
to uh porn movies with Kennedy and
obviously not reporting on that um uh
it's hard to imagine that happening
today certainly um uh so the
interactions that the media had with
candidates were less scripted but was
the president ation that the public got
any less
scripted uh well like I said the rules
were different I mean they were
different then and and so the
presentation wasn't authentic I mean it
really wasn't right but but it's a
completely different environment that we
live in now right right so um in the
2008 campaign I know that you that that
was a difficult sort of moment for you
in terms of where you were going toine
line up well I just had an
unusual situation where
I I I
uh I had a relationship with McCain and
the McCain people that goes back that
went back to I was like one of the only
people in the Bush campaign that were
actually communicating with the McCain
because I just had relationships going
back and I love McCain's campaign
Finance stuff and always just respected
him and his this sacrifices there's
there's not a lot of love lost there was
just because of the general 2000
campaign but but I maintain a
relationship there and then
later
uh we got together and he's you know and
I said if I can you know ever come down
and cut your lawn and Sedona or anything
I'm GL happy to do it it's a nice lawn
yeah uh and he said and so then lady
said would you come help me in the
campaign and I I really didn't I was
really kind of burned out and but I said
I'll kind of help put the team together
and at what point was this was this was
really early on really early on and then
so during the primaries yeah early in
the primaries I mean just right when it
first started and I I initially just
pledged to kind of put the team together
and drop in on a few conference calls
then as you Pro you will recall the
campaign melted down everybody quit and
i' had been just a volunteer to kind of
help out and I so I I stayed on with
that was late in 2007 that was kind of
middle 2007 like Spring 2007 it all
melted down and um and so I I I agreed
to stay on then I went full-time but
still in a in a voluntary status just
because he couldn't afford to pay
anybody and I I just kind of my my point
at that time was I just wanted to kind
of help him get his honor back right uh
and then things happened but what
happened is at the beginning of the
campaign I had met Barack Obama and I
liked him and and I disagreed with him
politically on on a lot of things but I
liked him and I also uh I liked what the
idea of his candidacy could be and
thought it'd be good for the
country and I didn't want to be the guy
the point man in a Republican campaign
doing what generally happens in
presidential campaigns I didn't want to
be the the trigger man and and and I
also didn't think it'd be good for the
campaign and I just wouldn't be
comfortable so I wrote a a memo to the
campaign the day I started which was
again early in 2007 I just
said I'm honored to to to work for you
and help you try and win the primary but
in you know and at this time nobody
thought Barack Obama was going to win
but I said if Barack Obama wins the
primary and you win the primary then I'd
like I'd feel more comfortable stepping
away at that point and uh uh and just
going to the sidelines and and then it
happened and I went to McCain and he
said oh yeah right I forgot about that
and uh but he was said listen said and
and and who did you end up voting for in
2008 for McCain I and I supported him
and and voted for him uh but uh it was
really hard to walk away at that point
because I put a lot of Blood Sweat and
Tears into that campaign and was this
great resurrection and comeback and uh
but McCain you know he's he he said it'
be very un mcain likee not to honor your
word and I appreciate all you've done
and God bless you uh and then and then
later I was you know given the way
things worked out I was happy that I did
walk away because a lot of things
happened that I thought would happen I'm
glad I wasn't part of it and uh anyway
so that that's kind of
that unusual Arc tassi so in in 2008
when when you all of a sudden are
covering this campaign um and and I
didn't know you at the time but I
remember
uh um even people talking about you as
if your identity covering that campaign
was not a journalist it was a black
journalist is that something that you
felt at the time and did you feel like
you were supposed to write about the
campaign in a certain way because of
that no I am a black journalist so it's
okay but I mean you know right yes and
and I'm a brownhair journalist but
but but you understand the implication
of what I'm saying it was almost as if
there was there was um there seemed to
be in at least some of the things I was
reading this idea that it would be
impossible for um someone to write about
this historic campaign in a way that was
equally impartial uh to you know what
I'm totally fine with that I was not
impartial I was very excited about the
possibility of an African-American
president and I said it and and I I I
you know I come out of opinion media you
know City paper was opinionated I've
always laid my biases out front I've
never and those biases include being an
African-American um my argument is that
more more people should lay their biases
out front you know so no I had I had no
problem with that I mean I I strongly
believe that the proof is you know in
the pudding you come read what I write
and you know you feel how you feel about
that like I always thought that if I
were good then that would that would
ultimately be what would matter matter
and so and then during that campaign
when you were seeing the things and
experiencing the things that were then
written about in the National media um
did your perspective on the value or
place of political reporting change at
all or did it change how now when you
read something in the newspaper um uh
about politics do you interpret it
differently you know I don't have a TV
and I threw my TV out in 07 or 08 and
literally yeah literally like not threw
it out the wi but L but took it down to
the garbage I didn't throw it out the I
didn't want to hit anybody um the
defenestration of Chris
M um but it was Chris Matthews I would
like cut Chris Matthews and there's
nothing personal against him it could
have been anybody right and I would cut
on the TV and it was very clear that
nothing was actually
happening like nothing was actually
happen like on a day-to-day basis
nothing like literally nothing I mean
but it was so covered in such a way as
though you know every little thing but
it didn't and like it was amazing were
you already on the campaign at that
point were already no no I was like
writing from home and I think this so it
would have been 07 I actually think it
was like late 07 so I don't think I even
started blogging yet I think I threw out
my TV
before I really do I really do you see
the 078 maybe I done solid madman and no
no see well you know another development
has happened since then you know but but
you know at at that point um I guess
what I'm trying to say was I really
began at that point questioning like um
what what what is actually being
communicated and it wasn't even just I'm
using Chris Matthews as an example but
you know it could have been you know the
daily newspapers too like you would
because there has to be a story every
day but how much information is actually
being conveyed you know so it was very
clear to me we have this conflict that
we have a lot of space and you can look
at that as TV time you can look at that
as you know inches in a newspaper you
can look at that as your feature well
but often nothing is actually I mean
these campaigns go on forever and
nothing substantive will happen and then
something big will happen I guess the
fear is that you don't want to miss that
you don't want to not be there for that
moment so yeah that's I mean that's an
interesting part of the dynamic that's
that's absolutely true is you know the
journalists have space to fill and they
can't stand static right right they
don't want a static story line so
they're they're pushing to create a
story line they're well is it is it
journalists who can't stand a static
story line or is it or or is it the
public I mean is it you know the people
who are watching TV I mean if you had
well it's clearly a demand for you right
clearly is a demand is it is it entirely
fair to say well yes this is journalists
who are doing this if you had if Chris
if Chris Matthews TV show was him for an
hour every night saying things are
basically the same as they were
yesterday I'm guessing that he he he
would be doing even worse than he is in
the
r yeah yeah no no question about that
yeah so right now we're living in an era
in which we have access to more
information than we ever have had in the
past um uh and access to more different
types of information than we ever had
have had in the past when it comes to
politics do you feel like we are being
well informed as a
public well let me take this opportunity
to jump into just an example of of what
you're talking about
um the so I mean the question is what
kind of information do we get from the
body politic and is it accurate is it
true and where's the sort of evolution
of that
Dynamic and I I I was the ad guy for
campaigns you know I did that's mostly
what I've done over the last 30 years or
so and um but and and I
remember when we were and I remember
producing ads and and we would be
creative I'll say creative uh but we
would never actually you know say
something that was wrong I mean we might
kind of color you know the way that we
wanted it soan you would never lie
directly yeah yeah and uh and then what
happened is that but that you know but
we we could get very creative uh and
then then there was a when you say get
very creative are you talking about like
different camera shots are you talking
about creative with the truth no could
kind of embellish what you've done and
uh and and that sort of thing but uh
but then as a corrective response to our
our expanding creativity the news
industry business and I I remember
specifically the first woman who did it
in Texas a news manager did you know
came up with a truth test they said well
we're going to start we're not going to
just let these things go out unfiltered
we're going to we're going to start
reporting on it and having uh you know
truth tests and and that had a huge
impact on us and what we did was that uh
uh this would
be late ' 80s
okay um early '90s right and so
suddenly and very healthfully when we
were producing ads for our campaigns we
were thinking in the back of our mind oh
this is going to get truth
tested and uh so we've got to be very
careful about what we say and how we
characterize things because when it
happened to the other side when somebody
else's campaign would get a truth test
and the truth test would say oh they
bent the truth or something we jump on
that our campaign would right we we'd
make an ad about that that they
distorted the truth and that would have
a you know significant impact because
people were saying you know this
campaign's not telling you the truth so
that was 20 years ago so do you think
that political ads have become more T
closely tied to reality in that time
more he he ask skeptically more closely
tied to reality then yeah no now I mean
so you the the implication of what you
were saying was that you became even
more cautious about embellishing because
you we did we did then so a corollary to
that would be that today ads are more
accurate because people are worried
about getting truth tested no that that
you're the second half of what I was
going to say is that over that period of
time what happened is that people became
sort of inured to that notion of the the
truth test right and and and reached its
absolute Distortion in this last
campaign and I just want to play two ads
and then then I I'll just play them
without any editorial comment you'll
remember these uh and then I want to
then I want to comment on them okay
here's here's one of
them welfare recipients were required to
work this by partisan reform
successfully reduced welfare roles on
July reduced welfare roles on July 12th
President Obama quietly ended the work
requirement gutting welfare reform one
of the most respected newspapers in
America America called it nuts saying if
you want to get more people to work you
don't loosen the requirements you
tighten them M Romney's plan for a
stronger middle class will put work back
in welfare I met Romney and I approved
this message okay so that's one ad now
here's the second
ad which was an Obama
ad
hopefully hope you ain't depending on
that MIT
internet trouble
here this is how inaccurate this hand is
yeah
[Laughter]
all right well I I'll just describe it
this this was the ad that uh Obama
ran you you can describe it and I'll try
and C it out well here well let let me
okay while you're trying to get that up
let me let me start with the Romney ad
okay um so that that Romney ad came out
and was was demonstrably false I mean
there just was there was nothing about
it was true
and uh and and and and when confronted
with the truth when there are
organizations as well as uh as well as
Publications now that that specialize in
in it's the second one is that one yeah
the specialize in reporting and and
studying political Communications and
being the kind of Gatekeepers for the
truth every one of them said completely
false completely false and the and
rather than than make a
corrective uh uh uh turn or uh uh rather
than edit the spot or take it down or
respond that or even even try to respond
that it was in some
way uh accurate the the Romney campaign
was
uh uh let me just read this to you uh I
don't think M Romney understands what
he's done
people's lives by closing the plant I
don't think he realizes that that
people's lives completely
changed when met Raman Bane closed the
plan I lost my health care and my family
lost their health care and uh uh a short
time after that my wife became ill I
don't know how long she was
sick uh and I think maybe she didn't say
anything because she knew that we we
couldn't afford the
insurance and and then one day she she
uh became ill and and I took her up to
the Jackson County Hospital and and
admitted her for pneumonia and that's
when they found the cancer and by then
it was stage four it was it was there
was nothing they could do for
her and she passed away in 22
days I do not think mitt Romy realizes
what he's done to anyone and I
furthermore I do not think mitt Romy is
concerned priorities USA action is
responsible for the content of this
advertising okay so let me just read you
a couple quick things here so on the
Romney at here was a here was
a A dispatch presumptive Republican
Presidential nominee Mitt Romney's
campaign has drawn fire for misleading
ads against President Barack Obama on
welfare but the Romney campaign said
Tuesday it's not concerned with being
labeled false by independent fact
Checkers quote fact Checkers come to
this with their own set of thoughts and
beliefs and we're not going to let our
campaign be dictated by fact
Checkers uh
so so you had a response from the
campaign saying we don't really care
about the truth I mean that's
fundamentally what they're saying we
don't care about fact Checkers and kept
running the ad now uh so now here's a
response on on the uh the Obama ad uh
let's see let me
um were you going to say something well
I was just and certainly the last thing
I want to do is is have this I don't
think M Ry understands what he's done to
people's lives by closing I don't I
don't think he realizes that that
people's lives completely
change r
b uh um I mean that that that the the
language there is is is not dissimilar
to the language in that famous New York
Times magazine article in 2002 or 2003
about um when uh uh talking to one of
Bush's advisers and his dismissal of the
reality based Comm community and that
that wasn't what the campaign and that
wasn't what the administration's message
was concerned with well I have a lot of
problems with the guy who wrote that
book read that right yeah and so all
right you know we all need to that can
be another topic for another day uh yeah
so I mean I never heard anybody say that
and you know I know that there's a lot
of things were in that book right that I
didn't say that were ascribed to me so I
don't know where that came from uh and
and I don't know anybody that believe
that so uh so now the other ad says this
the Obama ad was filmed by the super
pack run by former White House Aid Bill
Burton and features a steel worker who
used to work for a company that was
taken over by Bane Capital the
investment firm founded by Romney the
worker lost his job in health insurance
and the ad insinuates a link between
that and his wife's subsequent death
from cancer independent fact Checkers
have noted however the cancer patient
featured in the ad died six years after
Bane bought the husband's company that
she had her own health insurance through
her employer and the Romney was not in
charge of the investment firm when her
husband was let go um uh and then it
goes on to describe how the present
campaign said oh well that's a pack and
we're not you know that's a separate
entity we're not legally so they didn't
they didn't they didn't they they
refused to they just their response was
well you know we had nothing to do with
that we didn't we didn't coordinate we
legally can't coordinate and then it was
disclosed later that they actually had
been on a conference call with this guy
in an earlier ad that they've done so
they did know about this guy so anyway
there was just on both sides there were
just extreme examples of of of taking it
to the Limit where
where any Common Sense sort of uh
legitimate Outside Agency said these are
completely false and yet they refused to
even not only not acknowledge that they
were false and take them down they just
said well we we don't we don't care
about that and just push right on
through it so and were were those ads
that had uh significant adbis or were
those ads because I know there was also
a phenomenon in the most recent election
of essentially making incendiary ads not
even airing them just putting them
online and then essentially using them
as Chum for for reporters who would then
and they would get a lot more coverage
and exposure than the ad ever would have
that's a that's a whole another
development which is yeah I mean which
is the reality is that uh again this
goes to the whole the whole issue of ads
and their
effectiveness uh people don't generally
believe that so a lot of what happens
today is that the the political
campaigns are trying to get into the
larger Narrative of the of the press
coverage because that is seen as more
legitimate and
credible for viewers who are looking for
you know a more authentic messenger and
so you're right what the campaigns now
do is they'll create ads to try and get
a story about the ad in the paper or the
news coverage and really won't we used
to at least buy sometime you know we
we'd do this to sort of get coverage too
but we thought we had to at least
actually buy some time but it's got to
the point today where they don't even
buy the time they just put out an ad
right and they and they get the coverage
that they're looking for and so it's
this little game that goes on so before
we open it up um tan I just I want to
talk a little bit about uh your fear of
a black president piece the the piece
that nominator for National magazine
award um uh first why don't you just
tell us a little bit about about the
piece uh sure
um first I just I I'm sorry I want to go
back to this point if I can just a about
this a lot and I
I I guess what seems to undergo this is
this notion um and I think we kind of
got at this when we were talking
about how I the market M uh for you know
believing that something is changed wait
I'm sorry what do you mean the market
the market for news the the idea that
you know you have space to fill and
people are clearly buying that space and
people are clearly viewing that I don't
want to sound too cynical here but
um this sort of you know division where
you see you know people running as like
like like like you know you just
describe and I have you know no doubt
that you know when people are running
for president they they lie
I I guess I'm skeptical that there is
this
um I wonder how much people believe what
they want to believe today I guess
that's what I'm saying I'm wondering how
much any of this actually ultimately
matters um to what extent even you know
with like what you you're saying about
um the media when you say you're
skeptical about how much this ultimately
matters like how much like I I think if
you want to believe that Mitt Romney is
that guy you're gonna believe Mitt
Romney is that guy if you want to
believe you know Obama you know is GNA
do that you're going to believe it and
I'm skeptical to the point even in terms
of the media being a uh a a a a more uh
credible message I I wonder I think I
think that's a great point and that that
I think we should focus on that for just
a second because I think you're it's
absolutely true
that the the country has become more
partis has become more partisan and in
part it's become more partisan because
uh I mean Washington's more partisan
part because the countryes become more
partisan the countryes become more
partisan because people one of the
reasons is people become more mobile and
they can move to communities of
like-minded people and then they kind of
self agregate and and sort of you know
self approve and you know it becomes a
silo of information and belief Cascade
where yeah and then then you have the
evolution of the media which which
becomes increasingly siloed too and so I
I think you're right I think that
there's a huge shift in just the sense
that there's just a bunch of people out
there are going to believe what they
want to believe and they're going to
look for information so they're going to
see that commercial say yeah I that kind
of goes to my my confirmation bias
anyway and I'm looking for information
that will feed what I want to believe so
I think that's I think you're right
about that but so is that are we talking
then about
how the public as news consumers
can essentially create an information
cocoon where they're
only subjected to exposed to um uh ideas
news stories opinions whatever that
already reinforce their world view well
I think I think like there's an
assumption among all of us who who are
journalist
that God this going to sound really
cynical um and particularly I think
there's this assumption that if I
provide you with accurate information
um you will then you know uh make an
informed decision and I just wonder you
think journalists believe that I think
so I mean how I mean then what's the
value of information if you know if if
that's not true and I like we live in a
time where there's more information you
know available to certainly to Americans
maybe to the human population than ever
in in our history and I wonder how much
it matters you know like so let me let
me push on a little bit I mean
completely I I I very much agree with
the idea that um with with the
implications of being able to form these
information cocoons both in terms of
what we take in and also in terms of
where we live and who we see and who we
interact with but there were a couple of
moments in the 2012 campaign the 47%
comment probably being the the prime one
of them where that actually did seem to
affect the way that the public at large
was both view the candidate and view the
race right well that's a a a big
unfiltered moment right like that's not
I mean maybe I guess they they might
have cut that into ads I'm sure they did
certainly Obama in the second debate
made it part of his appeal but that's
the kind of rare unfilter just you know
any longate you know Rift that you
really really are not you know uh uh uh
going to see you know how how often how
often are you going to see a 47% tape
how often are you going to see something
like that you know where it can't really
be disputed um I don't know I mean Mark
you were you were talking about how uh
the ways in when was the last time
something like that happened Obama's uh
cling to guns and religion comment right
but that's like a line I mean this was
like I mean uh and his video you know I
mean this wasn't that kind of anomalous
Mark Mak yeah Mak Maka is probably yeah
and he lost right and he lost
right yeah I mean do you think that um
uh the media is essentially kidding
themselves if they are laboring under
the um under the notion that information
is going to affect the way someone views
a candidate or an issue or the world boy
that sounds cynical it's more nailistic
I think than
cynical I thank you I prefer that I
prefer that and I should clarify I don't
mean no effect I guess I should I don't
mean no effect but I mean I think
especially coming on in a time of blogs
and watching you know um go on sorry Mar
well I I think that's all true and I
think it's a matter of degrees and it's
and it's changing and it's shifting and
I think there are journalists who still
believe and and will continue to believe
and there's some Merit there some degree
of it which is true which is that they
they're trying to pursue what they think
is an objective fact and truth that
they're trying to communicate that they
hope that will be consumed and
considered in the debate but but whether
or not journalists believe that I mean
do you think that that do you is is that
a
fantasy no I I no I don't I I I still
think that there well I think that there
is and
perhaps My Hope Is My My My optimistic
side is that that in this revolution
that we're in the middle of of
Journalism uh where the pendulum has
swung that there'll be a point at which
the voters and the public will will
realize that that they are not getting
the truth haven't been getting the truth
and there'll be a greater premium placed
on communicators that
deliver what is you know that that
whatever the consensus body is that that
it is actually true because there
because they've been through a period of
time where the consequences for not
having gotten the truth become so great
that it evolves so you think like this
will shake out and then there'll be what
like trusted BRS for instance yeah yeah
yeah that's what that would that would
surprise I mean it seems like that's you
know returning to a a pre internet model
where you had Network news and a couple
of big National newspapers that could
sort of set a base National conversation
it's hard for me to see a scenario in
which we return to that well it'll be
different but I think in some ways it'll
be like that I think I think there will
be trusted Brands and trusted
aggregators and you know where
people uh you know I I I think it's
going to
evolve okay um uh why don't we open it
up I've already taken up more of my time
why do you if if you can because we're
recording if you can go to one of the
two microphones um to ask the to ask the
questions and and just introduce
yourself uh my name is Greg PC I
actually am the photographer here I used
to work for Hillen nlon U why is it
assumed that there was a golden age of
objectivity in political reporting I
mean if you look at the 19th century
there was it was highly politicized and
so it seems that the practice of
Journalism in terms of politics had a
brief period of objectivity when it was
controlled by commercial interests and
when those went away you end up then
with partisanship I I'm not um I from my
perspective I'm not trying to imply that
I think there was a golden age I think
that when there were a small number of
news outlets that set the national
conversation then you had a baseline
that regardless of where you fell in the
political Spectrum people were starting
from whereas now you know what what Mark
was talking about in terms of the
birthers or in terms of um you know 911
conspiracy theorists uh you don't have
that Baseline and so when you have
people disagree they're not disagreeing
about an issue where they AG
even that the issue is what it is um uh
they think that they're talking about
totally different reality so but I'm not
saying that there was some golden age
for objective reporting um just that the
implications of having a sort of
national um these National Standard
Setters created a different was there
one before was there one look in the
1890 was there National Standard Center
uh no certainly not in the 1890s no I
mean I think in the middle the the the
the mid century
yeah before and after there was so we
had this little window of national taste
makers mhm yeah well in the 1890s I
think it doesn't make sense to talk
about I mean this is a whole other
discussion but um it doesn't make sense
to talk about National taste makers in a
period in which uh you know to get from
one part of the country to the other
took weeks and what to other in other
countries you see right sure yes the the
even the idea that the media should be
objective is a very uniquely American
idea not the UK and and most of Europe
and most of the world does not share
that view certainly so in human history
in one country for a small s of time we
have this idea right yes I think we're
all okay with that we
are um Rodrigo Davis comparative media
studies in the center for civic media I
think you just said there's not a
conception in the UK that the media
should be objective as a British person
I completely disagree with that but um I
so you would disagree that so you think
the newspapers in the UK present
themselves as
nonpartisan uh if you're just talking
about newspapers but I mean I was
including broadcast media in that and
obviously we you know we all know the
elephant in the room the BBC right is a
slightly different situation because
it's state funded or it's state
subsidized subsidized yeah the majority
of its funding doesn't come from the
state anymore it comes from BBC
worldwide the private arm which is like
selling planet Earth and I I'm I'm even
even though you are viously have a
position of expertise because I the
amount of time spent in the UK I can
count on uh probably all my hands and
feet all my fingers and toes um I think
it's unquestionable that that the
dominant method of um the dominant
Paradigm for news organizations
primarily newspapers in the UK is to
associate themselves with a political
party or a partisan agenda that doesn't
mean that they then say and we can't
report on the truth but they're very
upfront about the fact that they're
reporting on those stories through the
lens of um a greater editorial Vision I
would actually say it's it's more
complicated by class than partisanship
because I think that backing of parties
is extremely tactical you know so the
sun being the voice of the white van man
you know at some point backs the Tories
when they seem to be in the ascendency
with with that constituency right anyway
sorry I didn't mean to I I have a very
different question um which is a
colleague and um are looking into the
impact of internet memes um on elections
specifically the last presidential
election so your binders full of women
horses and bayonets this kind of stuff
that spreads online and that people
remix and share um and I'm just
interested in hearing what you think it
means to cover these memes in political
journalism because we did see surprising
amount of like big bird popping up on
the front page of major news websites so
is this just just like covering any
other agenda item um or is it like a
process story like you know this
Troublesome meme came up and this is how
Romney handled it or are there any kind
of other existing paradigms of
participation in elections that that
these memes fit
into uh I find it to be I you I'll just
speak for myself but I found it more uh
to be uh a way in which here I am being
cynical again people who already agree
with each other talk and have in jokes
um but is your question how the the the
how the media covers those that's right
how does it them I mean this may be part
of that yeah
um I don't know because I don't know how
it goes beyond that I mean uh watching
Twitter I I primarily you know saw
remarks about binders full of women and
um it's like just like in jokes you know
that people traded amongst each other
mhm you know and I don't I don't know
that it goes you know beyond like
whipping up the bass I don't know that
it becomes much more than that um to me
what what do you how do you go beyond
this is something people are saying like
how does it like what's the impact
Beyond maybe you could tell I mean it's
the changing the discourse argument I
guess I mean you you seem pretty
skeptical that it's possible to change
the discourse through no no no no I
think I think it is but I just I wonder
like um my question back to you would be
what is the impact then um that it
changes the discourse because campaign
see these messages that kids are making
for partly for fun and they they
incorporate them so you know after the
big bird meme came out you might have
thought this was just throwaway but the
Obama campaign started referring to it
and using it right um and the same with
the binders full of women maybe uh you
know it's this was a great emblem of
like you know what the public was saying
about Romney and it becomes like a
weapon but isn't it just an emblem sorry
isn't it just an emblem of what their
supporters are already saying like is
isn't it you know the Bas talking to you
know the preferred candidate isn't that
the real discourse well I I think
there's the Assumption which may be
wrong that the kinds of people who
create these memes aren't necessarily
your party activists although they do it
as well it's a lot of the kind of
disinterested or you know allegedly
apathetic kind of you who aren't really
voting or aren't participating they're
kind of Bor with politics that's where
we would disagree okay sorry yeah I
shouldn't I actually don't mean that I
mean it's it's not that they're
disengaged or apathetic it's that
they're um they are tired of the
conventional means of engaging so this
is their way of engaging I mean one one
one question I'd like to raise is that
almost by definition when you're talking
about memes is that something that
someone created or did it become a meme
because you know 30 seconds after Romney
said binder's full of women in the
debate there that there that was you
know the number one trending topic on
Twitter and that that wasn't and someone
some kid or adult or anyone who said I'm
going to create a meme here it just
seized hold of the cultural imagination
in a way that um without those it it
probably would not have become that type
of story without something like Twitter
because I I don't think the Press was
going to treat it as the main story
coming out of that debate until it
became the number one trending topic on
Twitter but Mark did you you had a
comment about that well I I would just
say that it's
uh
uh well first of all I would say that
you know even though the the slice of
the you know the the the persuadable
voters has become narrower and narrower
and uh you know there elections are
still very close uh here and that that
something's affecting those unpersuaded
people ultimately although a lot of the
times I think I'm persuaded uh or
persuadable voters are people who don't
end up
voting uh but but you you're fighting
over a very limited pool and so any of
these things can affect it and so you
you fight over every inch of
turf um I was just going to say that
that I think that in in uh that many
ways what you're describing is just a
broader sort of of uh
sandbox of tools and toys that reflect
what we used to do just with with single
channels you know we we would try
something like notebooks would have come
up in a debate and we would have gone
out there and done a press release on it
you know and tried to have our
surrogates go out and talk about it now
you just have in a post debate in a post
debate spin but you know we didn't have
Twitter to do it and now that just
amplifies it so quickly but uh and maybe
gets to a different Universe of people
but in many ways it's just an extension
an electronic and modern extension of
many of the things that we used to try
and do just in not not as well yeah
that's that's something I'm really
interested and you know I don't pretend
that this type of spreadable remixable
discourse was invented with the internet
yeah so I'd love to talk to you more
about some of those pre- interet
examples well I'm an expert on
that thanks yes uh Chris Peterson
comparative media study center for civic
media um so the title for this talk was
um news or entertainment I'm very about
sticking
with well I also thought that that was
maybe like a a bad title um in in the
sense Title St probably that the
distinction um maybe and this puts it a
little bit into what you were talking
about with needing to fill airtime um
that there's an industrial context here
right which is that people watch TV or
read you know newspapers or magazines
for one of two reasons and sometimes
both you know one is to fill their time
in the de day that's left behind behind
work and sleep um and the other is to
have something to talk about with their
friends and that's true whether it's um
news reports The Weather Channel or
Gilligan's Island you think those are
the only two reasons that people read
newspapers fundamentally yes that that
that it's part of it is to just fill the
time in their day because they have to
do something and the other is talk about
it now what they're talking about with
their friends they may talk about for
different reasons and those things may
be more or
less
um connected to something that affects
their everyday life in a very real sense
well let me just so how many people here
today read an article in a
newspaper or a website or a website sure
and and how many of you talked about
that article with someone else during
the day yeah so maybe half of those
people and how many of the people who
read something during the day
feel like they have a surplus of time in
the
day no one's going to cough to that
though no he he will yeah so I mean I I
don't mean I don't mean necessarily I
mean there's a cognitive Surplus
argument that Klay shery makes right
about a surplus of time but I I mean
when you're filling your time in your
day I don't mean like you have a bunch
of LAX time lying around you might be a
knowledge professional where it's your
job to know things but it's still how
you know you're filling your time but
but the point that I I wanted to make
was this right that you can see a lot of
the reasons why pundit shows suck is
because they're they have to put on a
show every night right Chris Matthews
has to go on air every night and he has
to fill an hour and make all these
things I but there seems to me to be a
different motivation behind some of
these other sorts of media so tanasi has
written on his blog about how a lot of
the reasons for the blog is not filling
column inches or the advertising Revenue
that isn't coming in clicks per minute
um or clicks preview um but just because
it helps develop a an idea in
conversation with your readership right
and that you're writing because you're
working through an idea and you want to
think it that seems to me to be
fundamentally different for whatever
people end up doing with it than the
industrial uh context of filling time to
sell ads to people filling time to to do
something else where you have these
other constraints that are guiding how
long your work is how short it is and
when you need to get it
out the effect
may or may not be different but I was
wondering if any of you have an idea of
a potential shift from here are some
ideas I'm working through uh or or
towards that from here is time or space
I need to fill uh if any different
results might
emerge I mean I I still want to push
back against the the uh the the
underlying notion there I I think the
reason why people read newspaper papers
and even the reason why people read
punditry shows is because they want
narratives to help them understand the
world um you know if if if I'm reading a
story if I if I'm reading about today's
Red Sox game it's not because I want to
talk about it it's because it was
incredibly painful and I want a
narrative that is going to help me
understand that um uh and also you know
if I'm if I'm reading about what's going
on around the world it's because I want
both want a narrative to help me
understand the world and also because as
a citizen of the world I want to be well
informed it's not because um uh I'm I'm
either looking to fill time or hope that
I have something to drop into
conversation um so but I I'd be
interested in hearing both of your
thoughts about that you write for The
Daily Beast I don't know if you would if
you consider that column writing or
blogging but tanas you obviously blog
and I think that that the idea that
you're talking about is
um I'm not sure if it's a new form of
Journalism but you know it's almost
something that Andrew
Sullivan helped Foster on his site early
on which is you use a Blog to develop
your thinking to develop um uh your
perspective on a situation and it's more
of a two-way conversation
right yeah I um why just to get back I'm
going to push back on South push back
let me defend Chris here for a moment U
it might be helpful to U disentangle
like what media you're talking about you
know I I if you picking up the New York
Times um You probably a less app to be
trying to fill your time no one reads A
8,000 were New Yorker feature
necessarily to to to fill their time I
mean that's that's some something more
that you want
I don't know about like I think TV is
fundamentally different right I think
people do come home have a hard day and
I do think for a lot of people politics
it certainly was for me before I threw
out my
TV and even now you know I'll boot up
whatever you know on the computer and go
do you know whatever you know lazy thing
I'm doing you know um eat my dinner or
whatever um so I I do think for TV is is
is much uh closer to this notion of of
of filling your time than the commitment
that that that reading takes you know
you can't do anything else um in terms
of the second part um this for me goes
back to the whole notion of of
objectivity
um and when you say this goes back you
mean the idea of working out something
and and and letting the public see your
intellectual process yes because I think
uh for journalists for quote unquote
thought leaders for public intellectuals
the uh template has long been I am an
expert in this and you should listen to
me because of that right um and you're
talking about news and opinion yeah I
think just across the board and I think
even at at universities I think anybody
you know who had some sort of platform
in which they were granted the ability
to talk to large groups of people um
that what they expertise was how they
build themselves in general um and
probably exceptions to that that other
people here might be able to bring up
um I never felt like an expert I I I
felt really really curious uh and I just
I I I don't for me like the fundamental
motivation uh for journalism was
curiosity period um you know just an
insatiable curiosity um and that's more
what what what I stress you know that
that that I am in Pursuit and that's why
you come you know uh under the hope that
I won't just stop at something easy I
won't just stop that's why you come to
your BL that's why a reader will come to
you I I hope so I hope so that I'll keep
asking questions because that's what I
can only say that that was how I always
worked on stories you know I mean this
goes from when I first started it was
you know uh are you going to ask the
question after the question after the
question after the question are you
going to keep pushing you know um it was
that you wanted to know and so I you
know I worked for 12 years before I
started blogging when I started blogging
the notion was to then open that up then
let you know the person see you doing
that um but that was where I thought
journalism came from anyway you know it
was this notion that you know you went
in you dropped in and often you you know
weren't an expert but you asked asked
asked asked it's a great it's a really
good question uh um from my perspective
I think that
uh that ties in a little bit to my whole
No Labels effort and kind of the
conversations that we're having which
again are you know uh we're not trying
to claim all the answers you know we're
we're trying to create a a collective
dialogue and a dynamic by bringing
people together so uh you know that
that's that's where I see things
shifting and the dynamic changing and
getting some traction for that because I
think that I I think there's a there's a
growing appetite for that that we're
we're trying to throw a net around so uh
it's it's a it's a really interesting
thought before we get to Tom I I I'm
actually
curious I think that um the motivation
that you're talking about is the
motivation for a lot of journalists and
maybe even I mean I was I was reading
today uh um John MC talking about his
career and and what motivates him and
essentially is you know there's
something he doesn't know anything about
and he wants the answers and he's lucky
enough to be in a position where he can
ask them until he gets some right right
right um uh no I totally agree with that
but if you're
um cannot stay the same way if you're on
the uh campaign Trail for eight months
does that is that really what what what
mean can that say the same way do you
continue to have that same appreciation
for what you don't know yeah yeah can
can it be that way I mean is that is it
really cu osity at that point that that
is really motivating you if you're you
know and again going back to this notion
of how much is really actually happening
right you know how much of that can can
be sustained right yeah I mean well you
know cuz you've been there but you know
there's really nothing more boring than
being on a modern day presidential
campaign in terms of anything happening
that's interesting or different or
surprising covering
baseball more boring Tom yeah I'm um
thank you um everybody for for for
bringing this to the People's Republic
of Cambridge um and I don't think any
any visit here uh mark would be complete
without a little push back um so I've
got I guess one quick comment and then
two questions one is the comment is
obviously that that partisanship is not
obligately a bad thing you know um and
that the Quest for
bipartisanship um is often a way to mass
ask um uh sort of a short circuiting of
democracy in the in the solution of
contentious problems you know so I think
that there is a a a premise behind some
of what you said and I'm sorry a short
Circ say again if you know politics are
composed of Elites and you know popular
or or mass involvement and uh
bipartisanship is a tool that can be
used and I'd argue has been a lot in the
last many
years uh by political Elites to
shortcircuit discussions about for
example tax policy or all kinds of
things I mean you can run down a long
list um uh you know we have an elite
consensus on the way we should deal with
Anti-Trust law that leads to among other
things enormous media conglomerates that
make it harder and harder to have a
vibrant media ecosystem or extremely
large you know I mean there are all
kinds of things you can get very
nitty-gritty into details like that or
you can get into into some of the more
um sort of grander thematic issues in
which a bipartisan consensus is actually
a mask right for ways that the people
don't get get onto
things um but I guess uh I was a little
bit troubled during your a couple of
your remarks um when you supplied
examples of you know the Romney campaign
ad and the Obama ad and um the uh Bush
uh you know which says CH challenging on
the bush um uh recount versus the birth
of
crisis that you were at least tiptoeing
around the edges of false
equivalency um as I
recall uh when the the campaign was done
and people the various fact Checkers
looked at for example how many romni ads
were were bogus or or mostly bogus or
Pinocchio or whatever the things were
versus the Obama ads the Romney campaign
uh was in in in much more dubious shape
when it came to truth telling and that's
a distinction that's important cuz if if
one side of the partisan debate divide
is more committed to a reckless
disregard of the truth we got a real
problem if only because of the political
equivalent of gresham's law where where
you know bad money drives out good and
bad campaigning bad bad information
drives out good
information um so I wondered you know I
want to give you a chance to either I
don't disagree with that okay I don't
disagree with that so what do you do
about a political culture in which one
party is continuing to maintain a great
deal of power over the current political
process despite a wavering commitment to
truth telling well the particular party
that you're talking about in this
instance lost a presidential election
they there was a consequence yeah but
they retain the house with in ways that
look not permanent but but lasting well
you know voters can vote them out I mean
that's you know that's that's what
democracy is all
about well there is I I I take listen
I'm all for reforms that I don't like
the Jerry mandering that goes on that
creates protected districts and all of
that but you know uh it is the system we
have and I you know let me just put one
more thing to you because because you
you noted that in partisanship in
Washington is at least partly driven by
partisanship in the country and the
siloed nature of of our social life and
all that right and I'm sure that's true
but there's also been a lot of political
science recently on the impact of
leaders on followers opinions um one of
the big case studies has been looking at
attitudes about global warming which is
which is a subject I've been covering
since the um since the 80s um and you
see a really major change starting
around the time that uh George W bush
became President when Republican leaders
who had
been you know Republicans and Democrats
had equal had had similar disagreement
within the parties about the severity
importance and human causation of global
warming prior to that after that as
Democrats and the scientific Community
became increasingly convinced of the
reality of the problem um Republicans
increasingly opted for the you know uh
the the the skep so-called skeptical
side and popular opinions which had been
overwhelmingly uh in support of the idea
that global warming was a problem and we
need to take action shifted dramatically
with Republican identified voters
following Republican leaders there's
been other studies similar to this um
and I suppose that's something that you
may be trying to address with your
current efforts but it certainly
suggests that the decisions and
information choices and choices about
whether or not to be honorable
truth-telling politicians at the top
matter for the partisanship issue that
you seem to be very concerned with well
and before you answer let me because I
don't want you to need to say this so I
mean I think that um I don't want Mark
to become a surrogate for GOP efforts
more generally um and certainly uh you
know regardless of your view about
specific campaigns um uh and I've known
Mark in different capacities um for
several years and interacted with him as
a journalist and a source you know 12
years ago or 13 years ago um and he has
legitimately always been someone who um
pushed back against that within his own
party I don't know if that was also true
when you were a member of the democratic
party um and certainly I think in the
last couple of years has even more
vocally since you have been unaligned
with campaign if I I'm not I'm sorry if
if I came off as that hm I I certainly
don't mean that but I I I you know the
question is if the if the problem is
excessive partisanship and a decline in
truth telling and the awareness of Truth
by the electorate then the question are
what are the solutions and if the issue
is one of leadership voices driving that
that suggests different solutions than
if the issue is a siloed media
environment for example you know if Mitt
Romney went out there and said in fact
I've spent some time on it I've had I've
had I've had some spare time and you
know I've really become convinced global
warming is a significant issue
arthrogenic global warming is a
significant issue that would or would
not have an effect depending on how you
view this question so I guess the the
the issue is do we need to re-educate
our leaders or do we need to break up
our silos or or or you know I think the
leaders I think the leaders are feeding
those silos but uh I also think
that you know that again I go back
to you know you touched on it but I mean
I spent a lot of time and a lot of
column inches pushing back on the
leadership ship of the Republican party
for precisely the reasons that you're
talking about and that's why I think the
Republican part has been in Decline and
will not reass send until IT addresses
that par but problems like you've just
pointed
out and this
is so a very brief fellout question to
that if Romney had come out let's say
before he got the nomination and said
yes the evidence as you know Huntsman
did to some degree and said that I think
by the way John Huntsman is the co-chair
of No Label
um uh but he said that with Joe Mansion
who just was significant on the gun the
gun legislation um if if uh you know
Huntsman did say I think the Republicans
seem to stand with science um if Romney
had said that uh now that's progress
during the primaries would he would that
have hurt his chance of gaining the
nomination I don't think so you know I
think that uh you
know I I believe and I've seen plenty of
over the years of campaigns
that I think the big problem with Romney
was much the same problem with carries
that people didn't believe that he
believed what he was saying and they
believe that he believed what he was
saying okay I know uh and and I think
that people will support somebody who
they think has core convictions even if
they disagree with them over somebody
they agree with that thinks that they
don't really believe
it so then I guess to get back to Tom's
question if if we are in a situation in
which
for one reason or another we are uh
putting up for election leaders who
don't have don't seem to have core
beliefs that they're willing to stand
with um how does this cycle ever resolve
itself well I think do you think that
the crisis in the Republican party after
losing this election was sufficient that
there will be real change in that regard
yeah I do I mean I think longer you
spend in the desert the more you figure
out where the water is and and you know
I think that that for example I think
the Republican Party
could uh support somebody who has those
kind of bold convictions like a Chris
Christie even though he may not be you
know meet the 2008 primary purity test
you know I think that that you know
they're going to get to the point say
you know I like a guy who says what he
believes and he's strong and he's bold
and he's clear and he's and he's
principled and he's consistent so one of
the things that the GOP has been trying
to do very actively um since the
campaign
is broaden its appeal um uh tassi we
were talking a little bit just before we
began about one of these efforts um uh
when Ram Paul went to Howard and talked
there uh how did
that uh not too well not too well
um it's it's really sad uh because
so obviously folks looked at the uh the
whole numbers and figured out that the
Republican Party Republican vote from
last election was overwhelmingly white
and overwhelmingly white in a way that
it not necessarily uh one would think
that it shouldn't be uh folks
who at least from the you know from the
perspective of Republicans should be
allies of those that they should be
getting they did not get
uh ran Paul um who I think actually
could you know make inrs over a
long-term period someone like Ram Paul
uh came to Howard University and I was
actually disappointed because I think
there are some natural issues not fake
issues real real issues that he's
actually spoken out on for instance
prison reform uh uh the War on Drugs I
mean these are actual issues that people
in the African-American are talking
about these aren't like you know fake
sort of you know
fax people say things like oh the the
African American Community is is is is
socially concerned which is a big broad
sort of thing that might be true but
then you know when you start getting
down to actual issues drug war this is a
real issue prison for is a real real
issue that there's activism around
there's a base around people are
organizing it around you could get votes
around and he spent three qus or half
the speech lecturing in africanamerican
audience on the on African-American
history and the political parties this
is Howard University Howard University
is the mecca of African I went to Howard
University I'll clearly tell you all
about it how University is the mecca of
African-American in education they call
it the Capstone of neero Education
that's what the name used to be um there
is a requirement that every student who
comes into Howard has to take something
out of the African-American studies
African-American history
African-American lit I I was joking with
Seth it would be like me uh going to
Paris and saying I'm now going to give
you a lecture on vichi France in English
by the way you know and wondering like
and expecting you to receive me well
like expecting to be be well received
and I say all this to say that what that
points at is not even so much you know
uh problems with Rand Paul specifically
but you don't even know anyone to talk
to to tell you that this might be a bad
idea that that's a problem that's a real
real I mean we start looking at you know
we we talk about votes we talk about
who's running you know is there going to
be an you know other Republicans going
to put up an African-American candidate
but the real issue is who's behind the
scenes how many contacts do you have how
often do you come in contact with
African-Americans with latinos with
asian-americans with gays lesbians
people who are different than you how
how much contact is there I I have this
satirical letter I'm going to write to
rampaul but it actually is a very
serious letter and if you look at uh
what the Obama Coalition that that he
put together to this didn't happen
overnight this happened over a period of
40 50 years and they were nasty really
really ugly ugly battles but behind the
scene awkward moments that probably are
much worse than what Ram Paul went went
through yesterday but what counts as
your willingness to have those fight
your willing to you mean with the the
Democratic party building that Coalition
yes yes yes yes awkward moments between
you know pulling those constituencies
together African-Americans deeply
skeptical James baldman writes about
this famous scene with with Robert
Kennedy I mean just really really ugly
awkward bad bad moments between the
Democratic party and you know these
various constituencies what folks want
is some sort of uh uh feeling that
you're in for the fight and when you
don't care enough to even assemble
people around you to even you know rub
some elbows even have some conversations
before you decide to give a speech I
mean what are folks left left left to
conclude about that it it was deeply
deeply you know depressing right sorry
that was my
rant yeah um I want to ask a question
that's a little bit of a meta question I
guess of an opportunity to reflect on
the kind of conversation that I think
has we've been having today and um I
think it relates to an observation that
I've been making or sort of just
wondering about in conversations about
journalism in general so not just
political journalism but it seems to me
like there are these sort of two strands
of conversation about sort of where
things are heading or or or what sorts
of observations we can make as as Trends
um and the one side is that there's
there's a problem of frag fragmentation
of the sources of news or the audiences
and so that you know I think one point
in the conversation today um one of you
was mentioning you people aren't getting
the same narrative they they aren't
debating the same things and that that
could be an issue and that's the more
pessimistic side of of the conversation
and then on the other side and I feel
like these are the conversations that we
maybe more often have H have here in CMS
there's the the the more optimistic
opening of access um you know people
have more opportunities to be bloggers
or to you know find channels through
which they can Comm communicate their
ideas and there can be a more diverse
set of ideas communicated as a result of
of greater access um today so there's
this like very pessimistic and very
optimistic side of the discourse that I
think are those B why are those two
things opposed to each
other well maybe they're not I mean what
I'm asking I guess is sort of for your
Reflections on whether you agree that's
a pattern and whether I think my
question when I hear those two sides um
of the discourse which come up quite
often is you know why is it that it
seems to be so easy to look in One
Direction and see one thing and another
Direction and see another thing like is
there something more fundamental under
underneath that we're not getting at
when we have these kinds of
conversations you know was a good
question I part of the
problem may be that
actually that and we talked a lot about
truth and what is the truth um and maybe
part of the problem is that with the
additional information that we have and
sort of you know people can get whatever
information they want now right so if
I'm inclined to believe one way or the
other and I going to be more righteous
if I have what I think is my truth
behind
me and that's kind of what I see in like
the gun debate and stuff you know it's
it's suddenly I'm finding myself having
discussions with people where they they'
they're suddenly all telling me the same
thing so I know that they're sort of
migrating to and these are people from
all over the place it's like my cousin
and you know it's not like suddenly they
all got the same book but somebody out
there is like and you we know who that
somebody is in this particular
information like the NRA was like really
in a manufactured way feeding this
information in a very sophisticated way
so that people thought they were getting
the truth you know and then suddenly
becomes this Collective truth so that's
that's that's where it becomes
problematic I think because people you
know when they have these you know you
know it's not like the old days where
there was kind of you know three
networks with their version of the
reality we started with people's you
know migrate to now they can go to
wherever they want to to get their
version of the truth and they think it's
true uh so it
it's I guess that's the reason why I was
saying I'm not sure why those two things
are are in opposition because
um uh sense that we can create these
information
cocoons I think goes along very closely
with um the ways in which we are all
able
to generate information and put our
opinions out there um the fact that
there are more sources of information is
one of the reasons why it is easier to
create an information cocoon and for the
more sources of information to have um
uh a positive effect on society as a
whole you need to have people in that
Society who are actively seeking out
information that they might not agree
with and I think that's a that's in a
lot of ways goes against human nature
well maybe the tension in the question
is we think we generally think more
information is a good thing right and
yet maybe it's not necessarily having
good effects all the time maybe not I
mean I don't I don't know the answer to
that but I do think that there's an
assumption underneath both sides of this
conversation that you know information
the the point is to get at information
and as a historian of news I think my
question then becomes well you know
information itself is I don't want to
start sounding like the people who were
talking about those ads and saying well
we don't need to care about facts or we
don't need to care about reality but at
the same time facts and information
these are historical categories as well
and they do depend on the types of of of
media that that that are created to use
them and you know we didn't really have
an idea of information and then leading
to objectivity until um objectivity
until the early 20th century and so it
it just makes me wonder if part of this
debate needs to get at well what do we
mean when we even say information is is
is what fundamentally we need to be
Distributing and you know could it be
that there's some combination of being
much more upfront about so do you do you
think that that a that factual
information is a
construct I
Think It's Tricky I I think that the
concept of what a fact is is something
that has changed over time and I think
that the concept of what information is
is something that's been that's that's
been built through history and does that
mean that there is no
truth no not necessarily I'm not saying
that you know it's it's a it should
become a freefor all but I am saying
that I feel like maybe part of what's
happening is that there are standards
that are shifting that you know we we
still want to have some kind of standard
we want to have something to pin our
news on but could it be that we need to
be thinking about a a different a
different sort of underpinning and just
to give an example you mean other than
facts just to give an example I think
there was at one point in this
conversation someone mentioned that you
know maybe we could be more upfront
about the biases that we do bring to to
our stories and is there some sort of
combination of being more upfront about
opinions and and and and and more
reflective about what a fact might be I
don't know I mean this is getting into a
lot of speculation I think my my point
the question was just trying to get at
um sometimes the the the concept of
information that's underneath the
discourse is something that that perhaps
we
don't analyze enough or or or or not
saying that we should necessarily but
but trying to bring that into the
conversation of what's what's underneath
right yeah I mean I I I I have a I I
have a problem with the sort of
postmodern notion that that facts don't
mean anything um this is the tricky
thing I mean I I I I don't want to be
standing here
saying right that that's not what I'm
trying to say and I don't think that
certainly I mean yeah certainly
information has and and how we value
information is changed what we consider
information is change and the
proliferation of of um of news sources
of blogs whatever is one way that that's
changed now I can sit down on my
computer for eight bucks you know put up
a URS
write something down and that's
information whereas 5 years ago it just
would have been me talking to myself in
the corner and and that that that I
think has changed things in in real ways
but I just want to be careful that we're
not also saying that um uh the factual
underpinning of what it is that I'm
blathering about is mutable in that same
way um uh you
know you can you can and and let's take
the the berther example You can disagree
about whether Obama is a good president
or whether he should have been elected
or whatever but um you can't really
disagree not really you can't disagree
about the fact that he was born in the
United States he's not a Nigerian
foreign agent whatever um uh and uh yeah
so I get uncomfortable when we start
going down that sort
of relativistic
path but
what yeah that's I think that's that
yeah
thanks either you want to jump in there
sorry I didn't mean death no okay I like
facts um uh Roger Wilson I um I want to
ask is it accurate to say that we're
getting more
partisan uh party enrollments I believe
are
declining the
the the uh the the unenrolled numbers
are increasing so it seems to me we're
getting less partisan the parties are
getting less effective at delivering
votes and it seems to me that there
might be an
opportunity uh to deliver to Citizens
useful
information to help them make voting
decisions and other decisions of
citizenship that not being met by the
parties or the current uh
for-profit media well and I I'll let you
also jump in there but this that that
does strike me is even in just the
definition of partisan might be a little
bit what you're talking about because
you can interpret partisan as meaning
enrollment in political parties or you
can interpret it as the rhetoric that
the C that that the candidates and
campaigns are using and uh I think if
you depending on how you Define partisan
you get two very different answers there
yeah I the uh I think that both can H I
think both are happening I think that
that that you're right that
um that uh dedication to either party or
Allegiance has has fallen off and people
increasingly less party loyal but at the
same time I think there is more partisan
behavior that can be reflected
in the rhetoric and the the the general
debate uh and the and the heat uh that
that but but I think both those things
are true we probably have time for one
more just a quick oh yeah yeah please I
the other thing I think to recognize is
uh to the extent that and I'm not even
sure to extend that this was a more
bipartisan country or a less partisan
country it was always underwritten by a
kind of uh immoral consensus uh one
example of that immoral consensus is
obviously segregation and Jim Crow um I
don't think it's necessarily a mistake
that we've seen increased partisanship
uh since the Civil Rights Revolution uh
but it's not just that I mean it was the
suppression of uh gay and lesbian folks
it was uh that women occupied a certain
place in in in our society uh a lot of
the things that we had consensus on
about how uh a country should be
organized have changed uh so if you're
sitting in a seat like like mine
um this consensus was built on false
things to begin with um and to the
extent that we're now fighting um the
fight is a good thing for a lot of us
we've wanted to fight for a long time
anyway hi uh I just have a quick
question you had mentioned the about the
Michelle Obama where they were just
trying to hide the fact that you
couldn't see her you had to they play
told you where you had to see her very
specific yeah and that David Carr had
told you you should write about this why
right is this and I guess I'm still
curious that never got answered I I I uh
I felt you know it's very interesting
because I was thinking about like what
reporters should do when they do that I
included virtually none of that I
included none of it in the
story um but I think that I as I think
as a reader I would want to know that
the campaign is Gen it's like this is
what's happening as a reporter I'm
experiencing all this Stu so I I was
given a kind of a tough assignment they
didn't want to talk about race at all
and I was supposed to tell you what
Michelle Obama meant and you can't I
can't really tell you what Michelle
Obama meant and not talk about race so I
went and talked to a bunch of other
people um but I I I I get what you're
saying I mean I guess in that sense I
didn't feel like I wasn't writing a
process story um I just felt like I
didn't want any of that I just didn't
want it wasn't part of what I was doing
I didn't want any of it in my story at
all um but but your Point's a good one
no yeah
yeah all right well thank you guys um
and and and thank uh uh both of you I
know both of you you traveled here for
this which we appreciate I know tanasi
you didn't travel somewhere um uh which
um we also really appreciate this was a
fascinating discussion we we did not get
into Judy Collins at all um uh but we
certainly could have gone on um for for
some time and I ECT that we'll continue
part of this next week next Wednesday um
uh so this was great you know these are
just as a summary Point stating the
obvious I mean I I think that this
conversation is is a fascinating one but
I think it also reflects that we are
really in the middle of all these big
this Revolution and you know fascinating
and you mean we're in the middle of this
not like we are in the middle of the
action but this revolution or this is
unfolding as we speak and yeah and it's
uh and it's you know I think there's a
lot of perspectives because it's there's
a lot of things to shake out yet and uh
um and and I think that it could shake
out really well and it could shake out
really badly right right right all right
thank you guys